hello world welcome to see you playing
Zack attack your one good thing about
being in this slum best I get some other
opponent so this is not bad at all get
some different opposition ok so in
English opening here with CE pointy for
called the pod Vinick setup is six ok he
insists on playing um d5 but ok I can
answer that with a five what take 65 ok
should be or should be alright
okay so Knight to g4 yeah maybe I can
just can push it put it to the side with
G for now therefore I have 60 x Queen
takes it might be possible okay let's
just don't develop something
yeah I've got a good space advantage in
this position I try to make this this
night a liability my thread is G for now
which is duly ignored as usual um maybe
it's not a real threat um check it out
so you're Queen d2 taking this pawn
looks dicey God should be six coming I
don't really don't really like that ok
now um gee for his get just getting this
age foursquare interesting i can go h4
h5 ok
d for was hanging
okay so he doesn't mind me going to see
five maybe he just wants to no no no
notnot c5 he will actually take you will
take okay
so yeah he wants to I play Bishop f3 or
something like that you place the Queen
j5 then try wants to take and take the
foyer this is really possible
weird yes I was afraid of that move just
firing away when my position is somewhat
it's it's somewhat shaky really i see i
was thinking it takes with the rook okay
so he will take you for now hmm yeah
well this is obviously this didn't go
well I mean from an opening line that
was very questionable for black I got to
get this position okay
I can't believe that this is any goat in
with running around with the Knights
them that cannot be good at all okay h5
quay
very very strange stuff and use this
those pieces not only for its not doing
anything we should be 495 something like
that looks very logical also h5 might be
something
night c5 might come with the tempo okay
i'm shaking right and that shouldn't be
so bad 95 we should be a three or what's
the deal Quino three RT g6 song
I can take and go rookie seven here you
can take it you can take it for
background made oh my god you can take
it hahaha this is so sick this is so
sick check amazing um to still pursue as
a sword a good position it is still a
position actually check ok check you
know Queen h7 will win I don't believe
it it's really really great check check
check and Baloo he's got this miracle
backwards I'm late coming up check check
check check check check check check
check check check
black resign okay cut what a game no
words okay so i think here I know maybe
I'm seeing this wrong but I don't
believe in those night jumps tianjin
large black or gifts s about equal me
I'm wrong thot 97 b6 looks better but I
cannot probably refute it right away g6
is God f6 otherwise this would be pretty
strong just letting the night be a
threatening Bishop e3 22 but he has f6
and takes with the Queen for this threat
otherwise g4 would be extremely strong
because the threat which should be 322
is winning this piece but he has f6 it
just works like that yeah probably
Bishop f4 is wrong I was still trying to
play with this idea yeah b5 is creative
neither 5 was possible already had okay
yeah this is not bad I mean this is not
bad for him it really isn't an oops I'm
sorry it really isn't she played that
well yeah I now I've got problems really
have 6 there may be hope my whole
position is crumbling yeah I'm just
losing here if he plays a bit more solid
I mean age 5 i'm not saying it's bad but
he can play solid moves and just win
technically i think this is this is
murky already know yeah now here here
just win i mean but i managed to screw
that up rookie six wins straight away as
g6 cannot be cannot behold and now again
rupees six wins and I take and I
overlook the back
media check check check yeah I have a
million shakes but it's no perpetual
check check now i can create no check
check check check check Jabbar told us
he win actual jack king in check check
this is how it went right check check
check little bit late jack check this
change is so tragic King g8 this is the
engine giving check check check with
this isn't isn't that of a petrol how
are you getting out of that I don't see
it just irritated by the engine which
says minus 2.6 I don't see how he gets
out of it check check check maybe like
this so long check yeah probably
something like that okay what he did he
check went on to the suicide mission at
gave me a check made who okay thanks for
watching